ah Switzerland known for making
overpriced risk clocks long before Apple
but they're also home to the largest
food manufacturer in the world
Nestle notice they make all sorts of
stuff like KitKat's and soy baylin's
baked potato flavor or chocolate made
with child slave labor - dangerous baby
formula salt to developing nations as a
more healthy alternative to breast milk
which is great for those vegan babies I
guess closer to home Nestle bottle 7
different brands of water in the USA and
if you go by their websites 6 appear to
be delivered by just one guy look at him
water is one of those essentials we take
for granted but just like a massage from
a drunk friend going through a breakup
we expect water to be free but
understand there could be a catch to get
one liter of bottled water on the
shelves it takes 86 liters of oil and 3
liters of water that's like using a
whole sizzler buffet to make one breaded
shrimp and in California it's like using
a sizzle of our fav that's on fire right
now California is having a water crisis
the state is as dry as an Israeli sense
of humor and our food Overlord pals of
Nestle a sucking dry some of the most
precious water reserves in the state
including ground water in the desert
yeah that's happening what do the water
there is left underground in places
where there is very little water above
ground to put in a bottle and truck all
over the country to be sold and
delivered to your workplace by that one
poor fella
living local desert ecosystems dry and
residents needing to find water for
drinking washing and cooking from
elsewhere normally Nestle's bottled
water plants will be scrutinized for the
state's water authorities but there
Cabazon plant one of the biggest bottled
water plants in the country is on the
tribal land of the morongo Band of
Mission Indians and because they're a
sovereign nation by law Leslie don't
have to report at another location in
California the Swiss food giant has been
taking water from the San Bernardino
National Forest even though their permit
expired
in 1988 that's what we would call in my
country taking the piss and bottling it
but why haven't the Forest Service been
reviewing Nestle's permits for nearly
three decades
we have a lot to do there are a lot of
expired permits I have six hundred and
sixty thousand acres the National Forest
to work on and I'm just one guy when it
becomes a priority I'll be able to
because the worst drought in twelve
hundred years is low on the list of
priorities right underneath hire new
hydrologist when the rest of the state
is being asked to cut water use by
twenty five percent according their
slays own statewide records over the
last four years of drought Ness lays
water use has increased 19% and the
company insists that it's sustainable no
if you don't believe them that made this
brand-new campaign to make you feel
better about buying bottled water you
devil at Nestle we're concerned about
California's drought I have two raw if
California runs out of water we can no
longer make Arrowhead but we've got a
plan from today every time you buy a
bottle of Arrowhead water in California
just pour it in the ground returning the
crisp clean spring water to the place
where we pumped it out to sell to you so
you can feel empowered to soak the
drought by pouring it back into the
ground because a sustainable water
supply means a sustainable profit when
it comes to the California drought
mislay gives a damn
oh hi again to put this story together
we rely quite heavily on the
investigative work of Ian James at the
Desert Sun if you are interested at all
in the water politics of the Southern
California then you should definitely
look up the Desert Sun ending in James
and follow their work
you